hi Doug how are you I'm well I'm well
dan how are you I'm great your thoughts
first of all on Grayson Allen with what
we saw last night against NC state well
the first thing is he sucks he wasn't
any good you know for a cheered that
talented he didn't play well and NC
State it's more of an indictment of how
bad how poorly NC State has performed to
this point that you can see this kid
gonna spin Junior is terrific and if
they can figure it out there that team
you don't want to play in the NCAA
tournament that's for grace now I think
he's caught in this weird area of I
don't want to get punked but I don't
want to be a punk like so he walks kind
of walk through the huddle and I don't
think there's anything sinister on the
other hand like dude just walk around
the home you don't have to be some tough
guy and I grow their team Cadillac grit
and toughness and they're just not they
don't seem to have natural leadership
they don't have a point guard right now
they don't have no normal head coach
they're trying to integrate you know
three star freshman one Harry jobs is
not nearly as good as you ask for is to
injuries and so there's a lot of stuff
going on there and I think I think it's
pretty obvious he's having a tough time
you know compartmentalizing the issues
and just playing ball and knowing that I
love dude every team that's going to go
in there is gonna try and rattle you I
could see it's the same thing the same
thing with Odelle Beckham jr. once you
get a reputation leaves are going to try
and get under your skin you bump into
somebody we're going to try and punku
and see if we can you know bring out
that other side to Grayson because she
doesn't know how to be obviously doesn't
want to handle it but you know Seth
Greenberg saying should sit him down for
the year is he's insane you have to be
just gonna work through it man was just
college stuff and it's a perfect
opportunity for Jeff capable to show he
can run this program yeah I reacted the
same way with a Seth Greenberg because i
was watching the game in real time
village said it's not a big deal to
which I disagree it's a big deal because
it's Grayson Allen somebody else's
they're not and if I I don't know who
benefits by sitting Grayson Allen down
the rest of the year for a guy who has
intentions of going into the NBA
I don't know what his draft stock is but
I wouldn't draft him if I know his coach
or coaches are gonna sit him down for
the rest of the year and and you're
right he has to understand if you want
he's almost playing with his chip on the
shoulder like everybody's picking on me
and doesn't understand he's the reason
why everybody's picking on him he has to
learn how to get back to his freshman
year when he sort of played and had fun
and was you know at times the best
player on the floor he's almost
regressed here Doug I would agree that
unless some of it is they don't have
somebody they don't have somebody else
who command the attention as a point
guard who commands attention has only
remembers freshman via play for like
half a year he generally played and
filled at the end of the season and you
know he made a reputation based upon the
championship game which he was
spectacular but he's also the fifth
option you know one of those guys it's
barely on the sky report and it's it's
much more difficult when you're the
number one option so I think you know
you fast forward two years forward and
now we've seen the tripping incidents
and the weird crying incident on the
pond on the bench after he tripped the
kid meal on and and the you know the
indefinite suspension which lasted a
game and and look I don't think those
can get him any favors you know I was
pretty obvious last year either one of
those trips sit him down for a half sit
him down for a game you know make it
about the long play instead of the short
play and and you know yet now i don't
know if i don't know what Jeff capo
feels empowered do remember like cable
if this was really his staff he would
have an old head sitting over there next
to him he doesn't all those guys are
younger than him so he doesn't have
somebody to kind of give him the balance
of hey maybe she do this maybe she do
that but that thing's kind of a mess
doesn't mean they can't figure it out I
mean he imagined the Dukes in eight nine
feet and they're taking on over UCLA in
the second game of the NCAA tournament
that's that said if you take out the
second half of Miami who is a non NCAA
tournament team they the last you know
three of the last four halves first half
of Miami in both halves last night they
have a look very good that looking like
they're progressing the right way even
with Tatum coming around they're
starting to get some more production it
they're kind of they don't know what
their lineup should be
they don't know their leader is grace
now and head somewhere else you're not
shipping well he's not taking great
shots and not able to defend so they got
some issues there some first world
problems they got some issues talking to
Doug Gottlieb from CBS Sports I don't
know if CBS is involved in it I think
CBS TNT I don't know if it's a joint
venture you guys do carry the tournament
together but you're going to have March
Madness now starting in February where
basically the playoff selection
committee that we had in college
football was going hey this is the top
four or here's your top 15 this is what
it could look like now we're going to
have the field of 68 revealed once a
week for I think four weeks in February
how does this impact the college season
how does this impact March Madness I
don't think it has much impact over
other than it gives us a snapshot of the
kind of the predetermined bias heading
in the last month right in that how much
do you weigh what happened in November
how much do you weigh what happened
because that's really what's going to be
to reflection that the important
basketball is februari on right that's
when you are which you are against teams
that know what you're doing in league
play on the other hand what you do out
of league has some sort of value so I
think they're going to kind of show
their cards as you like here's kind of
the predetermined bias over the first
three and a half four months of the
season that we think and then let's see
how it plays out but you know look end
of the day that's not really what people
want what people really want is we want
to be in the selection room during the
selection process until that happens
you're not really going to satisfy our
desire as fans to know more about the
process and have a better feeling for
how each team is like what I have
recommended not that anybody's listening
to me from the n-c-double-a but that is
let us in the room of selection sunday
and let us take 15 minutes worth of
information out for how many hours
you're in there piece it together and
then give you you know some kind of show
or you know we can allow you to see this
and it can be modified edited so
nobody's you know put themselves out
there or you know they're somebody's
going to be embarrassed by something but
I would love to just see a little bit
that with some cameras in there to see
how the process works is is that
something so far-fetched down the road
here I don't think it is or shouldn't be
I think people are you know everyone's
afraid to have somebody here somebody
feeling sure yeah right I still have no
idea how Tulsa made dance a turnaround
it bad South Carolina and I agree I
agree like how do these these things
happen and and the idea that you're
going to now is you know show me the top
16 seeds and it's all over bed now like
that's not really okay it's a and again
I I kind of think we the the world has
changed I think we deal a little bit
better with information was that
sunlight is the greatest disinfectant so
if you just yes if you show us you and I
wouldn't think we're fans but we've been
it around this thing there's nothing
wrong with killing us the inside of a
meeting like look I'd love to if I'm NBC
sports network okay the network that
carries your radio show I would love to
have a camera with you watching the
games with your crew us all day sunday
how awesome would that be just listen to
tony dungy i mean it's it's no different
than what ESPN captured with the coaches
room like how cool is that during
natural chance your king all right so
you fast forward that to the NCAA
selection process and just have us in
the room like what alright so so
somebody mentions that Georgetown sucks
like you look gorge down in the heart
knows we suck this year like you know
there's nothing you can really and
they'll be good debates and there'll be
somebody support you somebody not and
again I think you know people feeling it
might get hurt in the short term and
long term like look that's kind of part
of what the process is this is what we
know what's being discussed maybe this
is how this is the it's the supporting
your work right we're here's the problem
here's the answer deal with how we got
through like that our own show your work
I want them to show you their work and I
don't think this this shows their work I
think this makes you think they're
showing you their work or they're really
not Doug thanks for joining us as always
danazol was my pleasure that's Doug
Gottlieb from CBS support the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience
you